So here's the brain of
a non-procrastinator.
Here's my brain.
Both brains have a Rational
Decision-Maker in them,
but the procrastinator'sbrain also
has an Instant Gratification Monkey.
So the Rational Decision-Maker
will make therational decision
to do something productive, but
the Monkey doesn't like that plan,
sohe actually takes the
wheel, and he says,
"We're not going to really have room on
theschedule for any work today. Sorry!"
The Instant Gratification Monkey
does not seem likea guy
you want behind the wheel.
He only cares about two
things: easy and fun.
Sometimes it makessense to be
doing things that are easy and fun,
but other times, it makes much
more sense to bedoing things
that are harder and less pleasant,
for the sake of the big picture.
Andthat's when we
have a conflict.
We need to stay aware of the
Instant GratificationMonkey.
We need to think about what we're
really procrastinating on,
because everyone isprocrastinating
on something in life.
That's  a job that should
probably start today.
Well, maybe not today ...